and president Trump's tough talk with
North Korea today should not come as a
surprise it's an approach that he's
taken for months remember this we are
settling and we're going to do something
now one way the other we have to do
something we cannot let that situation
fester we cannot let it happen little
rocket man he is a sick puppy North
Korea is a country ruled as a cult at
the center of this military cult is a
deranged belief in the leaders destiny
to rule as parent protector over a
conquered Korean Peninsula and an
enslaved Korean people this man will not
get away with what he's doing believe me
one threat in the form of an overt
threat which by the way he has been
uttering for years and his family has
been uttering for years or if he does
anything with respect to Guam or any
place else that's an American territory
for an American ally he will truly
regret it and he will regret it pass
joining us now with reaction are Florida
Republican congressional candidate
Lieutenant Colonel Michael waltz
co-author of Reaper Brigadier General
Tony Tata and US Army veteran Brett
velichkovich all right gentlemen I don't
I'm sure you've kept up with it as I
have and and it's almost like a game of
chess and clearly this is something that
has been is the way that negotiations
have taken place in the past but general
Taylor I'm gonna start with you first we
did get three hostages back and there is
apparently some destruction of nuclear
sites and a promise to destroy more have
we given up anything in exchange for
that we've given up nothing and we've
gotten everything that we could have
wanted before this the summit happened
and what we're seeing is the art of the
deal in action here judge and you know
live before our own
as for those who didn't read the book
they get to now watch the movie and
president Trump understands that he is a
commander-in-chief of the most powerful
country in the world and he mentioned
seven hundred billion twice you know it
during his press conference today and
that number is the size of our defense
budget and this was a strategic
messaging to North Korea he understands
the leverage that he has here and that
seven hundred billions number of our
defense budget is twenty five to thirty
times the size of the gross domestic
product of North Korea so if you're on
the North Korean side and you hear that
number that's an overwhelming figure and
then he just magically you know weaves
together the diplomatic information
military and economic elements of
national power and and really that's the
maximum pressure campaign that he
referenced in his speech today all right
Brett and alcohol go to you the the the
the the role of China in all of this the
president seems to have indicated that
after a second meeting with President Xi
of China that Kim Jong on seemed to have
changed his tone he signaled that I
believe it was yesterday
and playing puppet master this whole
entire time from day one this has always
been just as much in negotiation with
China as it is with North Korea I mean
do you think that the Chinese want to
see thousands of US soldiers two hundred
miles off their border sitting there in
South Korea so there
they've been playing us all along and we
have to be very careful what we do here
but I think what we've seen just overall
with these talks is we've been
witnessing today a master class in
negotiation that's been playing out on
the world stage the fact of the matter
is that these deals are all about
leverage okay and we're the strongest
country in the entire world we have we
don't need to listen to a country or bow
down to a country that has the economic
GDP of less than the size of Honduras
and so it's very important when it comes
to all these talks that Trump is very
careful about being too accommodating to
Kim jong-un because what it does is it
risks this recognition for him
of what he's always believed would
happen all along when it comes to having
this nuclear arsenal so this deal has to
get done but it needs to be done right
or not at all and in the end we've taken
back control here all right and Michael
I want to ask you about the you know
this morning and the president pulls out
of the summit the last thing tonight is
that North Korea is saying you know
we're ready to sit down at any time what
does that mean for people in the
military I mean that's that's your
background that's who you are
what is going on in the Pentagon right
now well president Trump has shown
strength from day one as commander in
chief and and I think he's been
absolutely right on North Korea since
day one despite all of his critics now
this is not President Obama who's going
to take the military option out off the
table before even gets to the table this
yo president Trump knows and has always
known that diplomacy needs the credible
use and needs the credible threat of
military force and not only do we have
that the North Koreans have seen
President Trump train and equip and fund
our military how it needs to be fun so
he has come into this with three key
preconditions in that military exercises
with our South Korean allies and our
Japanese allies will continue
denuclearization means exactly that that
it is full verifiable denuclearization
and that key here is that the sanctions
will continue so what do we what do I
hope to see next from from our commander
in chief is that another round of
sanctions the seventh fleet sitting off
the coast of North Korea and that for
everyone calling him a war monger
they're absolutely wrong this president
knows it's that credible use and our
veterans are cheering them on that is
actually going to mean peace through
strong right in general tato what about
the fact that there hasn't been a firing
of a missile by North Korea in months
well that that's exactly right judge you
know the for all of the left that is was
rejoicing this morning you know just a
digress for a second yes they've
defended Hamas they've they've
ms-13 and they've defended now Kim Jong
GaN in North Korea all in the same month
and that's that's a you know pretty
amazing if you think about it but
there's been no action from North Korea
militarily and as Michael just mentioned
we've kept doing our military drills we
kept doing NATO he kept applying our
pressure and and we're tightening the
screws every day and and that is the
leverage that the President Trump has
and he knows he has it and you walk away
from the deal if you're not getting the
terms that you want and that's what
President Trump is doing here and and
it's just very textbook what he is doing
and so he knows he's got the leverage
and he's executing based upon the being
the leader of the most powerful country
in the world as opposed to apologizing
as President Obama did and had sent in
pallets of cash to get detainees back
and all of that insanity right judge if
I can just jump in and remind everyone
President Reagan walked away from the
summit walked away from Gorbachev when
they tried to move the goalposts and
that's exactly how President Trump is
acting okay and Brett I want to ask you
one question I only have about 15
seconds left you know we talked about
China and the role of China as we
continue in this tariff a back and forth
China is sending us a signal to by
saying we can manipulate kim jung-han
correct yeah absolutely and I think
that's the biggest problem with this is
that you're negotiating with a
superpower here but the fact of the
matter is that our military is ready we
hold the cards right now it's we left
this deal on our terms and right now
we're in the best position we have we
can be for these negotiations so in the
end this is a deal that's meant to be
for the entire world it's not just
America and we can't fail at it and the
president won't okay all right thank you
to all of you